so it looks like a lot of Marvel fans
are going to be getting what they have
wanted as we have reports that not only
is Miss Marvel going to be getting a
season 2 but also moonnight a lot of
people have been waiting for an
announcement for a season two for both
of these MCU projects on Disney plus and
it's definitely extremely exciting news
but what does it mean for the current
state of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
where are these projects going to take
place in are they going to come
somewhere in Phase 6 before Avengers
Secret Wars or are they going to be
coming in Phase s after Secret Wars we
also have a little bit of news about the
Kang versus Doom situation whether or
not Marvel Studios is considering
getting rid of Kang altogether or if
they are keeping him in the MCU as the
main big bad villain whether that is
recasting Jonathan major or Jonathan
major remaining in the role if he is
found innocent so a lot to go over today
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Marvel news for the MCU
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month so these two projects
might be a part of Phase 6 it looks like
we are slowly starting to learn a little
bit more about Phase 6 because keep in
mind we still don't know that much about
it technically Marvel has only
officially announced three projects for
Phase 6 the Fantastic 4 and the two
Avengers films so moonnight season 2 and
Miss Marvel season 2 Could Fall In The
Phase 6 category and we can kind of
assume that Marvel is going to kind of
pack the end of Phase 5 and all of Phase
6 with quite a decent amount of projects
I know the plan for Marvel Studios is
for them to kind of pull back on content
a little bit but at the same time they
do have to build up to one of the
biggest events that we're ever going to
witness Avengers Secret Wars According
to some insiders this is going to be
even bigger than Avengers endgame and if
you just think about what is possible
for Avengers Secret Wars with the
Multiverse all of the old characters
being able to return like Toby Maguire
Spider-Man Hugh Jackman's wol Arena's
returning we could get the original
X-Men back and plus of course not to
mention Robert Downey Jr Scarlett
Johansson and Chris Evans could return
as well so this could be bigger than
Avengers endgame if they do it right but
the new Avengers team we know has to be
built up as well and we're looking at
these characters that introduced in
phase four like moonight Miss Marvel
shanqi and we haven't exactly see them
kind of get with the other Avengers
characters yet we know that Wong
basically recruited shangi for the
Avengers and we know that the tin rings
are most likely Kang technology it was
made pretty obvious in Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania plus we still believe
that the Bengals are Kang technology as
well after all they have the power if
they are together to open a portal into
another universe that definitely sounds
like Kang technology so there are still
a lot of stories that we have not
brought together yet and moonight and
Miss Marvel both getting a season 2
makes a lot of sense if you think about
kind of the premise for both of them
moonight essentially took us to Egypt
kind of ancient Egypt and we talked
about the gods while Kang's story in the
comics essentially begins in ancient
Egypt Nathaniel Richards which is Kang
the conqueror's real name in the 31st
Century discovered time travel
technology created by Victor Von Doom
who of course is Dr Doom from there he
travels back in time to ancient Egypt
using a sphinx shaped ship and he
becomes the pharaoh ramut who we have
recently seen in Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania he was a part of the trio
of kangs the Council of kings that we
saw in the post credit scene so here
there could be a pretty big connection
between moonight and King the Conqueror
and if they're going to do a season 2
part of that will probably focus on that
connection with Kang because if it does
indeed come out in phase six it's most
likely going to come out after Kang
Dynasty but of course before Secret Wars
so moonnight will most likely be a part
of the huge fight in secret Wars so
season 2 is going to have to build up to
that so making Kang or Rama Tut kind of
a central point to that would connect
moonight very very nicely so that could
be a big story of moonight season 2 that
and of course he doesn't think he has
konu anymore but we know he does plus
not to mention Jake lley so a lot to
unpack there for season 2 really glad we
are getting a season 2 I really enjoyed
Moon Knight and we've talked about this
a little bit but Miss Marvel season 2
just makes sense as well if you consider
the fact that she now has both Bengals
and apparently was even able to control
them better than darbin did but of
course we could probably say that it's
because she's a mutant don't forget
about that so her mutant genes are
probably what gave her the power to be
able to withstand the power of both
Bangals which is why darbin couldn't
handle the Bengals but Miss Marvel could
now she has both and again most Insider
have said that the Bengals are indeed
Kang technology and we assume they are
as well especially again if you consider
the fact that they can open up portals
to other universes so we're not sure if
Kang is going to want back the 10 Rings
or want back the Bengals or any other
weapons out there that he might have
created but we do know that they are
definitely connected to King so to bring
Miss Marvel even further into Avengers
Secret Wars and we know she's going to
be a main character of the MCU moving
forward after Avengers Secret Wars as
well it would make s That season 2 would
focus on both Bengals and how they're
connected to Kang the Conqueror so I'm
definitely looking forward to Miss
Marvel season 2 as well I did enjoy
season 1 however I believe at the end it
kind of fell off in the writing area the
show started off really great but the
writing just suffered at the end so I'm
hoping they do a really good job with
the season 2 because I think it has a
lot of potential and again Aman bani is
perfect as Miss Marvel and like I
mentioned we do have a little bit of an
update about the Jonathan major
remaining Kang situation and the
situation of if Kang is even remaining
the big bad of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or could Marvel be considering
making Doom the main villain of the MCU
moving forward which is what variety
said they are considering well keep in
mind that recently Insider Daniel rpk
stated that Marvel Studios is still
moving forward with Kang he said they
may introduce Doom but Kang is still
going to be the main focus let's hope
that is true however Insider Jeff Snyder
recently revealed on the John Roa
podcast basically that he wasn't sure if
the next Avengers film is indeed going
to be titled the King Dynasty and he
said that the next two Avengers films
which we'll just call Avengers 5 which
right now is King Dynasty and Avengers 6
Secret Wars could simply just be secret
Wars part one and Secret Wars part two
if Marvel Studios goes down this path
that means that Kang might not be such a
prominent figure in the MCU moving
forward he could still definitely be the
main villain but they could have a
variant of him like a beyonder variant
like we've heard is going to appear be
played by another actor again this still
really all depends on if Jonathan major
is found innocent or if he is found
guilty Marvel Studios is obviously
considering all of their options which
is why we are hearing so many different
reports I don't doubt that these
insiders are hearing what they're saying
they've heard I believe them but I do
think Marvel is considering literally
every option moving forward which is why
we're hearing a few different things I
would like to think that if Jonathan
major is found innocent he would
continue on playing King the Conqueror
in the MCU and king would continue to be
the main villain you don't need to bring
Doom in save him for later and have King
the beyonder variant of King whatever it
may be the king Trio am mortis ramut
Scarlet Centurion whoever it may be have
Kang played by Jonathan Majors Remain
the big bad of Avengers Secret Wars but
Marvel is clearly considering not having
the next Avengers title be Kang Dynasty
and maybe they will simply do what Jeff
Snyder says and make a secret Wars part
one and a secret Wars part two it's an
option for sure for Marvel Studios but
we'll have to wait and see in the
meantime let us know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below are you excited for moonnight
season 2 and Miss Marvel season 2 and
what do you think Marvel should do with
Kang currently let us know your thoughts
in the comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on the MCU you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof